[Music]
brian laundry remains
at large brian laundry remains at large
i thought that it was confirmed to be
his remains that they found i really
found it someone's remains next next to
like some of his personal items right
like a journal and something else he
probably killed that person left her
bones and ripped out half his teeth and
like sprinkled them around
and then he's probably just hiding
somewhere don't you think that's just a
crazy
conspiracy theory
that he's hiding yeah no because his
remains are inconclusive
are they really so what does it say
this like this dude
the way he
took
this woman's life was not smart you know
what i mean yeah i mean i i
i guess in theory are you saying there's
smarter ways to take a woman's life
there are definitely smarter ways to
kill someone yeah not that i would know
yeah i mean didn't he kill her and then
come home
meet up with his parents yeah go camping
with them
and then he disappeared after something
like that
and now they found his remains autopsy
of brian long's remains came back
inconclusive like what are the remains
doug
no manner or cause of death was
determined and the remains were sent to
an anthropologist for further evaluation
could the remains be you know what i
mean
he it's not like he could just like lose
a limb and then just cruise around yeah
he'd be toast somewhere yeah the word
remains is very vague
yeah
skeletal remains like he he probably
just like found some wild
baby bear ate it
you know left his backpack and like left
the bare pelvis there and was like this
should do it
and he's just out running around bro
that [ __ ] is like honestly this is scary
man yeah i think it was just loose yeah
uh the remains described as skeletal by
northport police department were
confirmed to be laundries after a review
of dental records
oh so their teeth
yeah seems like oh so they just don't
know the cause of death they do know
it's brian
so yeah he's deceased wait what
how is he deceased with his whole
skeletal
body is not there
oh it's inconclusive meaning how he died
is inconclusive yeah yeah the results of
the autopsy were inconclusive oh copy
that
but i mean
we have to assume he killed himself
right
or starved to death or
starve to death
maybe
that dude was on the run like how many
squirrels can you eat before you
are like losing health bar yeah i guess
if you're at 33 health
squirrels ain't gonna cut it
that is true
that is true
energy lows
yeah if that's all you have in your in
your inventory is another squirrel like
you're like switching through your
inventory there's nothing else not even
like a granola bar nothing squirrel and
notebook yeah you're dead
like you're going to starve to death
cause like even killing a squirrel is
like gonna start to take effort yeah you
run out especially with a notebook yeah
yeah
yeah how the hell are you gonna yeah
bro i wasn't sure yo i watched that show
alone
did i tell you about this no
i think we discussed it yeah the way
that dude killed a squirrel he just got
a i thought he wasn't really technical
he grabbed a handful of rocks it was
just like like shotgunning the tree i
thought he was gonna say he grabbed it
and just pulled it in half
yeah that's actually the humane way to
kill a squirrel
he looks at the only cameraman hold its
head hold his head for me ah
thank you he just kept throwing handfuls
of rocks at a tree and then it just
[ __ ]
he got one
that's pretty dope actually it is
i i wonder how much meat is on a
squirrel
probably like what
cash said i own one because like because
of ollie
oh nice i think ollie's got more meat
than a squirrel honestly
does he ever bark at squirrels
um
no we don't have too many in our
neighborhood
gophers no okay well we did we killed
the [ __ ] out of them okay
killed those [ __ ] what do you
do
we like we hired like a gopher company
it's [ __ ] up but
they just like man a gopher company
to get rid of them oh oh a gopher
exterminating company yeah i don't i
don't know a gopher company would
probably provide you with gophers yeah
oh [ __ ]
we get them exterminated we call the
wrong people
so we put 20 gophers in it was that's
what you wanted right we filled you up
you're all good topped y'all every hole
yeah
yeah there's about 20 holes here build
your holes with gophers
i was like is there a humane way of
dealing with them and our contractor was
like no
he's like we we would just shoot him
like he's talking about when he was
younger he's like he's got a bb gun
i'm like dang bro i don't want to do
that oh we could pull them in half too
if you want you'd rather honestly
blender feet first bro normally
so
alina hires this gopher extermination
company
and
elena's like
uh
okay so you can get rim's like yeah it's
like so how do you get rid of them the
guy's like are you sure you want to know
and elena
she just you know yeah
you know it's like probably one of those
like
you know
interactions where you're buying a
service and you're just like yeah yeah
sure and then it was too late to say it
was like the glow stick yeah yeah for
sure i want to know
he's like well we're gonna put a trap in
the ground and then as they try to exit
the hole they'll just get locked down
and then they're just gonna decay in
there oh yeah
like the other lobsters i didn't yeah
yeah
like the ones i left the dog yes some
[ __ ] person commented it was like and
the worst part is is you ruined this
beautiful gift from your diver friend
it's like
i told him he didn't give a [ __ ]
i'd over your beautiful gift
i'm dying at the thought that a dude
would put a kidnapped white woman and a
lobster on the same level
wow how dare you
we must find this lobster killer cody co
um
can i tell you some annoying house [ __ ]
this is like on the same plane as the
gopher thing right just some [ __ ] you
got to deal with you know you don't need
permission man you can tell me whatever
okay i gotta vent for a second then go
ahead okay so i come home right we're
gone for like five days yeah come home
sunday
busy busiest [ __ ] week of the year so
far is this this week right left all
these [ __ ] brand deals to the last
week of course because i'm an idiot yeah
so i'm stressed as [ __ ] about those i
gotta film
three [ __ ] videos right we got this
and then i'm doing trillion chilling
trillionaire mindset um and then like
eight other [ __ ] things
okay and we come home gotta kill a
lobster kill lobster making another
brisket yeah you know it's just just so
many things dude come home and come to
the kitchen and there's just water like
on the ground i'm like what the [ __ ]
dude love it what happened round two
yeah i look up and it's just spilling
out of a light fixture on the roof
just
and i'm like oh no
so immediately i run upstairs because i
was like someone left a sink on or some
[ __ ] yeah nothing upstairs nothing i
can't find the source of the water call
a plumber he comes over
cuts open the drywall on the roof love
when they do that [ __ ] takes it off goes
oh yeah that's mold by the way [ __ ]
sick
turns out the ac unit was just leaking
for like months yeah all the wood's
[ __ ] up yeah yeah you might have to
rip out your kitchen cabinets
there's a chance now that i might have
to renovate my entire home
yeah
[ __ ] slaps honestly
you